China's move towards a free market
economy in the interview Lee jung-jae
the Chinese government banking
supervisor he'll eases endearment mr.
Lee you've taken a stand for a social
market economy at the moment the
National People's Congress is in session
will there be a great leap towards a
social market economy English tongue
Saltalamacchia chhath kibum the mano
Nera sorts of other I've worked for the
government for 19 years in this time
I've been intensely involved in
implementing economic reforms well and
that you know you go last fall the
party's Central Committee approved a
move towards a more market-oriented
economy the Machine ethology jeevitha
that's why we're optimistic the People's
Congress will confirm this as the future
direction for our country the shinbone
shellac so you got to let see that sang
it from the hui that's okay what is your
greatest hug know what Korean that
personally I hope that we can tackle
some long delayed reforms to our
financial system that includes state-run
banks sushi and we must improve the
security of the financial system what is
the fee thunk winds will vouch why is
the government resisted private banking
for so long ah which is on that function
encounter in recent years we've actually
allowed private banks means you got the
sector is developing very slowly good
it's difficult for investors to start a
brand-new privately-run bank they don't
have the experience and there's a lack
of leadership often there's a shortage
of capital however we must open
ourselves up more in this direction
that's also true of state-run banks
which are not listed on the stock
exchange with the written set the
oscillation bong foreign banks operate
in China and a very tight regulations oh
gosh dad does this reflect a fear of the
disadvantages of the Western financial
system mock mandas earning millions a
lot of old charulatha gym china has been
a member of the world trade organization
since 2000
hunting that ever since banks have had
appropriate access to WTO regulations
you will float than that Western banks
have noticed one thing though that you
do the more strongly established they
are in their home market the harder
things are for them in China opossum the
local banks here open countless local
branches the foreign banks can't manage
that could build a key wins it's a lot
about father so what aspects of the
Western financial system would you like
to avoid in China I one point you
thought that cat by and large the
Western banking system is more developed
than ours so we have a lot to learn on
the other hand in 2008 we saw that many
of our fears about the disadvantages of
a system without rules were justified
the changes you know EG you may both
classes that's why the most important
thing for us now is to study the
weaknesses of the system damage and to
use that experience to consider how to
do it better other ones woman you can
get Bobby Lea there are still people in
China who opposed these kind of
financial reforms who are we talking
about in this case what you're the kind
of your to go for yes we must deal with
many opposing factions leaders exporters
were very much against reforms to
interest rates uncle and changes to the
way the currency is traded a good health
but we didn't let it derail the reforms
since 2005 currency fluctuations against
the dollar have been possible sequin a
yellow bottle need yeah you probably
persuade powerful opponents of reform
Doug innocent what are we chapter and
that's so she should Jessica it's less
about convincing individual opponents
and more about bringing all the parties
together so we can make a
consensus-based political decision
eventually the results of reform will
win over the most hardcore opponents she
holds it was the same thing when we
revalued the renminbi upwards you and
deletion the exporter's were afraid
they'd sell less to the rest of the
world sweet but what happened was quite
the opposite Yoli the show photo between
each other
honest I finished you managed a much
bigger reform package when you developed
a health care system for rural residents
and farmers they don't have that in
India doesn't even America's national
health care system is only a few years
old why did you start that project so
early at quartz and vomiting of food I
matunga fun gender male yahushua and can
ascertain 15 years ago I was vice
director of the Reform Commission and
was responsible for changing the health
care system to local in 1998 I traveled
across the country and visited hospitals
in every province sekai-ichi thalman it
became obvious that rural people were
suffering because they had no health
insurance Nepal what's that had to
change don't you know back then as part
of my duties I negotiated with the
finance ministry on behalf of the Health
Ministry you can imagine just how huge
the resistance to change was people said
it was too expensive and contrary to
age-old tradition a lien which holds
that families take care of themselves
but the politburo didn't listen to them
it went ahead and the reform process
began in 2002 the new health insurance
scheme for rural people was instituted
that's why I can coming up with health
insurance for 800 million people was no
small project who opposed it then and
what were the obstacles it was the first
project of its kind in Chinese history
project undergone border hang around to
go tell we always heard the argument
that China could not break with its
long-held traditions I was very moderate
in my demands pull da way at all that
and once the government decided to
develop that kind of insurance system it
became a great success 1channel kept in
a memo the army ID reform discuss you
succeeded in reforming health care in
China before the Americans managed it
what can they learn from the Chinese
experience in a fire Hong dish in Islam
something each other and so what
churches or the Posada what their pools
one can help us all that just we can say
with pride that our reforms have been
very successful
it's helped rural populations and also
many city dwellers altogether a billion
people are now insured by my passionate
woman asleep he has a freed up Dida
maker in the United States there are 60
million people who lack any kind of
health insurance not sleeping yet has
the cathedral mother in any case we have
to pay much less only it's between about
50 and 80 US dollars a year so that
makes it much easier if you can see that
nonetheless the Americans could learn
the importance of giving everyone at
least basic insurance you know ansible
assists in commuting what's more
difficult building a health care system
or reforming the financial industry
finance industry or shall hear that song
go it's difficult to say I'm quite
possibly the only Chinese politician who
knows both areas well both are very
complicated reforming the financial
system is complex because many other
economic sectors depend on Finance
Circuit rule of O'Neill that means that
the effect will be felt in many
different areas you thought it wouldn't
eat oh sure but it's different in
regards to health care reform what
automates what people's health obviously
comes first and citizens of China place
a very high value on their health but
with this reform it's not just about
health insurance per se but also
improving hospitals and medical
treatment there are still many things
that are wrong and it affects every
single person in our country that's why
we've concentrated so much on this area
that's what you've developed so far is
only a first step what are the big
problems and challenges that you see
ahead in this deep tradition at a pusher
Gong Gong castries in solution Yin all
right it's not the first step we started
off with a blank slate over 10 years ago
Jubal teach there was absolutely nothing
in place vida it was a long and
difficult journey but along the way a
billion people got insurance job I you
know meet Josh 800 million of those are
people who live in rural
areas and 200 million our city dwellers
ding lalla listen cheating san ka na
material that you enjoy this year we
succeeded in giving back about 340 you
want to each insured person with
attention yet ten years ago that was
unimaginable she thought no one was
counting on state support and heal it so
high you no one thought that way you got
so high you should cook each other when
it happened it was an unbelievable
accomplishment for China's gaya sona
masuri yogurt in DC de dos de su su get
aug deshita number what career I mean
that sig associate aha as for my role
China's Medical Association gave me a
prize for medical and technological
research which I egcg it's a very
prestigious Science Award in China an
amazing honor and for the first time an
economist wanted instead of a doctor and
the father so she knows hood she took
another show promised why is the social
market economy a modeling for China took
a tumble a canker kassin that you should
know Mortensen over 30 years ago we
realized that we could not continue with
a planned economy but this kind of
change takes time talking here
especially in regards to attitudes yeah
it takes a very long time to change
people's habits and their minds so
easily that kandisha tomatillo soup on e
Santiago Drummond John Doe yaya han ji
ji ji Hyun's oil palace in beijing
joseph so she endures all the kids
Istanbul the social market economy as
we've called it in china since 1992 is a
model that fits us very well we've also
learned quite a bit from Germany to what
I doubt you can tell the others but
things are changing all the time guy
who'd had all these now it's been
decided that the market will play an
even greater role and the state will
interfere less compete and to the
functional one transition a bar but
you've also learned from Germany that
this kind of system can be very
expensive what mentally dark
oh shoot oh gotcha pawan amazed odisha
gotcha Germany is not the only country
to have that problem father so if other
European and South American countries
have similar difficulties with this kind
of social system risks becoming a
bottomless pit want to want to connect
you would it's important to help the
poor chori that but of course lazy
people also take advantage of it and in
our opinion we must be careful of this
doctor everyone knows that Germans are a
very hard working people and lazy people
take advantage of the state and a
hard-working country how it can happen
anywhere we're already thinking about
that our goal is to help poor people not
lazy people hello mr. Lee thank you very
much